what's up Zoomers it's your favorite
time of the week Wow leave your entries
eNOS already closed I'm sorry little one
Felix when he sees his fans are turning
him into them his most hated me no way
oh my god it doesn't work anymore oh I
did something I don't even hate the meme
let's just speak it's I'm just fat yeah
I hate it okay I've already uploaded
this one because I I saw it and I didn't
understand the new upvote icon mobile of
users whose upload icon is still the
same I don't get it
why is this garbage on my sub reading
down vote whoever posted this I'm gonna
say it I'm gonna say it I'm gonna say it
P P small - that's illegal for send him
to jail oh my god this war crimes this
man has committed war crimes stop him
why does he have more shakers than I had
you best seek asylum quick because we're
coming for you seriously though you guys
crack me up that's hilarious
you can't stop me he's too powerful he's
right he can't be stopped now it's
already too late
here it is again ready complaining about
the new upload I could mean not updating
the app download small PP hate the
blinking Gaea meme his sub red yeah this
is well if you're new to the subreddit
this is what it is me hoping to see some
fun wholesome memes this is what I get
people roasting me epically that really
looks like me by the way meanwhile paper
is a symbol of freedom fighters in Hong
Kong I seen this good keep posting Pepe
who cares I'm so done with that good job
Hong Kong Jesus Christ police shut Mike
Pepe is a symbol of freedom let's change
it gamers when my daughter says okay
Zoomer to me in 2040 do not cite the
magic to me which I was there when it
was written oh yeah okay Zoomer in the
future damn that's gotta suck I
okay boomer is blowing up it's such a
big meme it's so dumb it's been an
underlying meme for a long time but it's
just blown up now William Shatner his
went off on Twitter because someone
called him okay boomer millennial oh
okay boomer than you n-word like what
okay boomer seriously grandma
ah look at that handsome boy a bit each
girl falls for you me wholesome pose
I enjoy thank you very nice this is why
everyone needs grandma's at least one
person will say you're not ugly you're
not ugly smash like on this video
Felix what is hair O'Brien I've never
seen him Minecraft veterans what is this
I am so confused why does everyone know
herobrine I'm a true veteran I was there
before he was written don't cite the
deep magic what problem gene send a kiss
all okay hey I donated to all right I
deserve some credit as well okay him
knock knock who's there
Doris Doris who door is locked that's
why I'm knocking awesome I like it yeah
let's let's bring it back to the dad
joke level Amazon will now deliver
inside your home and record the whole
thing order PJs on Amazon go to bed wake
to someone putting PJs on me me what in
the holy Amazon employee yeah this is an
old thing I remember seeing when this
was launched look they literally just
put it there and closed the door and
that's it and everyone started crying
about it but like oh my god don't use it
if you don't want it and then media try
to spin it as it wasn't safe they used
someone to hack it they use the hacker
to hack it I got two words for Amazon
hell no then don't buy it don't buy it
you don't have to buy it so annoying
redditors have an all-out Civil War
about the colour of the upload button
reddit changes upload button redditors
what how could they do this
yeah everyone keeps talking about change
the upload button and then changes I
haven't seen it change though what's I
can't tell if I'm being trolled oh god
this is a Boomer joke it's just to
identify boomers people arguing over the
new upload icon me a mobile user game I
kind of don't care yeah I kind of
freaking don't I kind of mother flippin
don't care whoever made this big peepee
if any billionaires wants to do a
pro-gamer move now is the time because
the number of trees for 20 million is 69
420 I already did that I already did
that no one dare don't you dare the up
up me me with a zero it's my number my
number most played games of steam steam
most uploaded videos on PDP pewdiepie
yeah oh oh Cowboys be like are you kids
with their little jokes you were say
soldiers when they hear popcorn in the
microwave gamers when they hear someone
opens a bottle of soda
redditors when YouTube rewind is right
around the corner like I want them to
get up but at the same time they can't
mess it up three times in a row like
they just can't I doubt I think they'll
be fine Felix I'm such a dad now me now
knowing why might say I couldn't run
across the road what oh there is another
no stop game press ENTER to start me
presses space game starts anyway that's
a pro game remove me preparing for
YouTube rewind 2019 damn it's really
that soon huh
don't worry memory whine will be the
redemption arc as always ok here here's
some feedback for YouTube what you need
is Will Smith going yeah again he needs
to start it up again it'll be such a
good meme just feature my wedding that's
like free upload points no one's gonna
want to dislike that show mr. B's
planting trees yeah just do a montage
it's disgusting oh is that how it looked
like yeah
and that's the worst thing that's the
worst thing I've seen oh good so good to
get the way take it away
Oh hoof using a single format combining
nine of them am i recording too early
I've seen this next year we should have
a hash tag team ocean where we raise
money to clean up ocean yeah I've seen
that am i recording too early what this
happened what people think of parents
have peers really is yeah it seems
pretty accurate I'm dumber than you
think basically when the wrong soccer
team scores everyone in the stadium like
that yes that's hilarious thank you my
see I've bought a ring that has the
letter M and F I've already made a joke
to her don't worry gamers minecraft fan
that's what it stands for
mom I'll have a date today be careful
dear
sex no to know who really killed Jeffrey
Epstein God God did it this is terrible
upload I liked this change bad change
bad change bad times 24 I'm such a dad
now no I'm not wait I shouldn't even
joke about that
in conclusion he is dad now okay cool
gamer
Felix why can't I find a guy like this
huh onion hey Felix no he likes his mom
he's literally the guy
right I'll even look like my mom with my
glasses Jesus Christ dude
I'm actually transforming into boomer
how did Sweden avoid World War two
don't hate me I'm Swedish yeah it's
pretty accurate in Sweden we don't we
don't really talk about the World War
two history we like to pretend that that
didn't happen I'm smart you're dumb I'm
big you're little I'm right you're wrong
and there's nothing you can do about it
okay boomer sorry I have boomer PTSD
whenever I hear it okay boomer I when
the phone was tied with the wire human
were free boomers love this stuff I love
it so good
Felix minecraft playthrough at the
beginning Felix minecraft playthrough at
the end ok Zoomers i love the comments
that says oh I'm missing Felix went on
adventures I've explored everything in
the game where should I go oh the water
temple is really cool for the fifth time
Wow
at least I'm trying to have fun like I
don't know when Felix became the mean he
swore to destroy I never dead dance this
is illegal I will report you for meme
crimes can't plant a tree because I
don't have a card so I've been growing
and avocado tree and it's got his first
leaves today I'm doing my part well done
sir well done and the thumb of one rate
I'm kidding I'm kidding I'm kidding I'm
kidding I'm kidding I'm kidding
doors were discovered in first century
people in $0.00 I can't believe I laugh
at that well then source right
you're currently somebody's crush you're
not just wrong you're stupid yeah why do
people keep saying this at least one
girl is fingered by you lies
filthy lies even when someone's told me
when I was a kid me like hey this girl
told me that she likes you I really know
that's a lie
I don't believe it why there's nothing
to play mom I don't like it pewds mom
it's chicken Pew delicious finally some
good freaking food it's weird how it so
distinctly I remember looking at the
onion and being like no this is
definitely not
mom can tell the different guy in white
so my dog can have one more tree to pee
on oh I feel like I've seen this too why
is it showing up PC users the upload
button is white mobile users cartoon
characters when they fall off a cliff be
like alright this meme still here for
whatever reason okay here we can observe
the prey putting hands in their pocket
to avoid their natural and most
dangerous predator handshake brah I had
people compliment my handshake people
like wow you managed to do it
some people are like oh I'm sorry I'm
like Jesus Christ dude you can't shake
my hand
I won't disappear or die or anything I'm
sorry I shouldn't shake your head it's
fine
I know I have to do it also three people
said wow you're actually taller than I
thought and I'm like oh effing and then
one person was like you're sure I'm
sorry but you're filled with stinky lies
another fallen soldier mm-hmm this is so
sad never have been
the real reason I will never be a dad
kids then rain rain go away come another
day little Arthur wants to play kids now
whether clear things fix fix it for you
I don't understand it I don't get it I'm
a Minecraft veteran but I still don't
understand cuz I never used sheep in
Minecraft when I make a man trying to
get to live there but it gets a mam
Robair instead a surprise to be sure but
American there if you enjoyed this video
right now smash like on this video
smashers guitar drums bass vocals this
will be the greatest band ever epic
let's do it gamers waterproof socks too
awesome but how the hell are you gonna
wash them yeah that's true actually
yeah they'd be so stank maybe if you
turn them inside out
big brain that's right boots made a new
celebrity at our school is that the
t-shirt no way
I gotta send that to Jack and her over
right now the child the trial give us
give us a check giveth it to child yet
they're so scary
this random guy walked they know my
picture weird though he smell like
meatballs really you're gonna do me like
that really it's my face like that what
is wrong with it
teenagers in 2040 why is no one in our
generation born in August millennial
dad's you wouldn't get it
oh I get it okay thank God I passed the
boomer test Keanu Reeves 55 goes public
with his first girlfriend in decades
it's enough to make a grown man cry and
it's okay so sweet happy for them people
like LeBron James youtuber PewDiePie is
more like than LeBron James
we did it gamers needed a new face for
the sprite cranberry bruh bruh come on
sprite show that you're down with the
kids they wouldn't do it sprite is
cowards
people who up vote button is still the
same I see no God up here other than me
yeah why is mine still the same haha Wow
I who cares
Jesus Christ [ __ ] Zoomers people on
reddit argue about what color the upload
button is red it turns the upload button
white people have read it what the
cinnamon toast Frick is this yeah I
don't get it the only boomer we cannot
insult is Keanu Reeves oh yeah we can
insult him come on new poll what social
media do you use the most out of these
reddit Instagram Tech Talk Facebook we
won mr. story we want oh my god Niall
nineteen I write a wheelchair all day
but I will ride you all night damn now
calm down la ma why don't dead people
just wake up holy that's awful the same
letter b pd q oh my god they look the
same you know what thing that really
grinds my gears is how 15 and 50 sounds
so similar who invented those letters
it's so annoying every time someone has
cloak I go oh it's 1550 no 15 what 1/5
okay how do I keep controlling reddit
with my anger other people if I don't
make it to that mailbox before that car
does I does I will die feelings if I
don't shovel these there's my neighbor
with that oh my god brah do you see
these stairs can I get a better angle on
them I have to shovel those stairs all
every winter every winter it was pain oh
and this is the garbage that place I
locked one of my friends in here one
time and then they went and told their
mom and then I got in trouble like come
on come on [ __ ] there's like wood to it
such a short time it was such a short
time I got into so much trouble for that
so stupid alright we're done with Lu I
hope you guys enjoyed this episode if
you did I would be happy if you smash
like subscribe join the biggest army
nation on nation
check out the figurines they're almost
out link is in description and see you
guys tomorrow bye bye hey we're all
excited about the new game that's coming
out and I can't wait to play it it
starts with the letter P can you guess
what it is here the pie pick ceiling of
course what you thought it was Pokemon
dumbass you stinky brainer
you